ざわざわざわ
先生：ばんばん（本を叩く音）
先生：休み時間終わったよ～
生徒：へー
先生：はい
先生：じゃ～学級委員長挨拶
はじめ学級委員長：あ、起立！
ぎーぎー（椅子の音）
はじめ：気をつけ！
はじめ：礼！
ぺこり（おじき）
先生：はい、おねがいしますー♪
先生：いいよ、座って
先生：はい
先生：みんな合唱コンクールもう
だいぶ近くなってきているから
合唱の練習しようと思うんだけど
机、じゃーまず、皆下げようか
はい、机下げて～
生徒：はー、めんどくせーぇ
やれやれ
合唱：いま別れのとき～♪（ばらばら）
合唱：力信じて～♪（ばらばら）
合唱：この広い～♪　この広い～♪
合唱：白い光の中に～　山なみは萌えて～♪
（ﾌ~）
女子学級委員長：男子！　ちゃんと歌って！
合唱：～♪
指揮：もうこれじゃ合唱コンクール
間に合わないよぉ～（泣）
うわ～ん(´;ω;｀)
女子：しほちゃん泣いちゃったじゃーん
どうすんの男子ありえな～い！
別女子：ちゃんとやってよー！
ガヤガヤ（言い合い）
男子：ちゃんとやってんじゃねえかよ！
男子：帰るぞ！
女子：待ちなさいよ！
ヤンキー：なんだよ、うるせえなあ！
女子：合唱コンクールなんだから
ちゃんと歌いなさいよ！
ヤンキー：歌ってるっつってんだろ！
男子：おい、どうすんの？
ガヤガヤ（言い合い）
オタク：やあっ、やあっ、やあっ
やめろぉぉぉぉぉー！！
うわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁー！！
合唱：遥かな空の果てまでも～♪
合唱：限りなく青い空に心ふるわせ～♪
合唱：自由を駆ける鳥よ♪
はじめ：自由を駆ける鳥よ♪（大声）
合唱：ふり返ることもせず～♪
合唱：白い光の中に　山なみは萌えて～♪
合唱：はるかな空の果てまでも　君は飛び立つ～♪
合唱：限りなく青い空に♪
熱血男子：ちょ、ちょ、ちょっと待って待って！
ちょっと待ってもらっていい？
あのさ、もうちょっと声を出していこう！
もう直ぐだから！
ね？
あと二日後だから！
もっと本気だせるよ！
自分の心…
伴奏：（失敗）
伴奏：もう一回、最初かやります
指揮：もう１回やってもらってもいい？
伴奏：（失敗）
指揮：歌いだしの最初のところからやろうかっ？
指揮：歌いだしのところからやります
伴奏：（失敗）　合唱：しろ…
伴奏：ごめんホントにごめん…
女子：ちょっと待ちなさいよ！
ヤンキー：うるせえよ！
女子：間違いなんて誰にでもあるじゃない！
女子：待ちなさいよ！
ガヤガヤ（言い合い）
男子：なんで卒業ソングなんだよ！
男子：間違いすぎだろアイツ！
ガヤガヤ（言い合い）
オタク：や、やめろぉぉぉぉぉー！！
わぁぁー！！
指揮：じゃー今日はもう当日だから
皆気合い入れて頑張りましょう！
ｶﾞﾗｶﾞﾗｶﾞﾗ…（ドアの音）
指揮：りこ！　来てくれたの？
ざわざわ…（喜び）
指揮：じゃー、皆
りこも来て全員そろったことだし
優勝目指して頑張るぞ～！！
全員：いえ～い！！（拍手）
（エンディング）
ガラッ（扉の開く音）
（すすり泣き）